early over the hump of the general  election and now veteran northern nevada  congressman mark  amade says he may actually run for  governor in  2022. as any practical person knows  if you're going to do something like  that you have to have a pretty good  organization statewide  and you've got to get through a primary  first because there'll be more than one  elephant  running around because i i don't think  it's news to anybody but they think that  governor sissel act  in some ways has made himself vulnerable  for reelection  i'm sure he doesn't agree with that and  i'm not going to be disrespectful  but it's like so so there's a lot of  people kicking tires right now  and we're certainly going to kick our  share of them here  the congressman says sign ups for the  election are just a year  away from march